aquí tenemos tres rectas numéricas
distintas y cada una de estas rectas
numéricas tiene estas marcas aquí está
el menos dos el menos diez el menos 5 al
menos 11 y debemos averiguar cuánto vale
el punto azul en cada recta entonces el
incremento en cada uno de estos espacios
no es necesariamente por uno puede ser
por más de uno ahora bueno al ataque
vamos con la primera recta cuanto vale
este punto azul en la primera recta la
distancia que hay de menos dos a menos
diez vamos a averiguar cuánto es eso
para saber cuánto mide el punto azul
entonces de menos dos a menos diez a ver
veamos que hay que hacer para llegar de
menos dos a menos 10 debemos movernos
dos espacios a la izquierda eso equivale
a restar 8
ahora mover nosotros dos espacios a la
izquierda equivale a restar 8 otra vez
menos 10 menos 8 es igual a menos 18 y
mover nosotros 2 equivale a restar otra
vez 8 menos 18 menos 8 eso es igual a
menos 26 entonces este punto azul
equivale a menos 26 otra manera de
pensar en esto sería en pensar que si
que si dos espacios equivale a menos 8
entonces un espacio equivale a menos 4 -
2 menos cuatro es igual a menos 6 menos
6 menos 4 esto es igual a menos 10 aquí
serían menos 14 menos 18 menos 22 y
menos 26 muy bien vamos muy bien ahora
vamos con el segundo con el segundo
problema tenemos aquí el punto que está
a la derecha iniciamos el menos 11 y de
menos 11 al menos 5 que que hay que
sumarle a menos 11 para llegar a menos 5
hay que sumar 6 cierto menos 11 6 es
igual a menos 5
entonces estos dos espacios equivalen a
seis entonces cada uno de estos espacios
equivale a tres
ahora vamos a sumar de tres en tres
menos cinco más tres aquí sería menos
cinco más tres es igual a menos dos
menos dos más tres es igual a uno
positivo y uno positivo +3 es igual a
cuatro acá fue menos 26 y acá tenemos 4
positivo muy bien genial entonces vamos
ahora con el último la última recta
numérica aquí tenemos menos 7 y tenemos
ok cuánto vale el punto azul muy bien
para para llegar de menos 7 a 1 debo
sumar 8 está distancia de dos espacios
es igual a 8 y si nos movemos otros dos
espacios a la derecha llegamos al punto
azul es igual a sumar otros 8 18 es
igual a 9 también podríamos pensarlo de
esta manera si dos espacios es igual a 8
entonces un espacio es igual a 4 menos
74 es igual a menos 3 menos 34
114 es igual a 5 y 54 es igual a 9
terminamos